[Music]
this is the twelfth talk
end-of-year for philosophers in the
midst of history here at the Frank Lyon
Berg and this time we're talking about
somebody who I'm very interested in and
have been reading since I was quite
young and that's Albert Camus can't say
actually understood much of what I was
reading back then hopefully I understand
more now and what we do in these talks
is take important philosophers like you
know everybody from Plato although I
have to hona Arendt and we talk about
some other thought and key ideas but we
locate them in relation to the
historical situation that they were
coming out of and in some respects then
had an influence on so there's a back
and forth they they're products of their
history but they also help to produce
history and with Camus he was really
deeply involved in the history of his
time he engaged in a lot of reflection
on the wars that were happening you
notice that his his life essentially
begins you know with a war which he's
too young to remember he lives through
the Second World War he goes through the
Cold War dies before the Algerian war is
actually brought to a successful
resolution and was taking a stand on
that he also was involved pretty heavily
in leftist politics and and you could
say movements but wasn't very happy with
a lot of the leftists of his time and
we'll talk about that in a bit and he
was really you know I would say a lot of
people think that you know they hear the
word Albert Camus and they think you
know mythos if Isis and the stranger and
they think of you know and that is part
of his work but I think that really the
the central theme of his ideas and and
the thing that preoccupied him through
his whole life is how to live ethically
in a absurd world in a world that
doesn't have any intrinsic meaning and
will you know anytime you try to
describe it some is going to knock it
down or disappoint you and so we'll talk
about how we we get there and I would
actually say this book right here is
the most important one the rebel which
he wrote later on for for thinking about
those those ideas he he developed in his
thinking over time too he wasn't
somebody who just came up with some
ideas stuck with him ran him into the
ground he was continually working
through these these thoughts in relation
to the world that he was seeing so I
think he's somebody who's particularly
appropriate for this this series and if
you're willing to indulge me I'll tell
you about how I first came to read Camus
and encountered him so I was in probably
think either middle school or high
school probably maybe the summer between
that and I had an uncle who read a lot
of books and he actually had our great
uncle who also read a lot of books so he
might have gotten this book from him and
he was living in the basement of my
grandparents house where I would stay
over the summer and I was looking
through the books that he had and and I
saw this book the myth of syphilis and I
thought well that's cool because I knew
about Greek mythology and so I said can
I borrow that book and he said yeah I
couldn't make heads or tails of it here
right so I took it and of course there's
very little about syphilis in it until
you get to the very end of it and it's
all the it begins by saying there's one
philosophical question and that's of
suicide and I was like that's kind of a
strange thing to start with and and so
you read through it and and at that age
there were a lot of themes in it that
were very captivating for me but I don't
think I understood them very well and
there were a lot of things in there I
didn't understand it at all and then I
had these essays after that that didn't
seem to have anything to do with the the
first essay you know they'd be about
shoes and you know or on or things like
that so I just kind of put it down for a
while and then I you know I got to
college and I became a philosophy major
sort of threw a chance and the place
that I went to college was very
interested in existentialism as a matter
of fact they were so behind the times
that they thought that that was
cutting-edge philosophy and so everybody
had to read Sartre and Nietzsche and
Kierkegaard and people read Camus but
there Camus was looked at kind of
suspect he wasn't a very good
philosopher he's a great novelist don't
bother reading his philosophical works
and and actually I didn't back then so
that waited until that I got to graduate
school and I started reading his
philosophical works and I thought well
this is actually quite good you know I
could actually do something with this
and I I find in him I don't I don't
share some of his his basic assumptions
but there's a kind of tenor to his work
that I find quite admirable he's not
willing to take easy solutions he's
willing to say when he thinks he's got
something wrong he's willing to say I
don't know about this or that and he's
really fundamentally about trying to
find a place in this this universe that
he thinks is cold and unforgiving for
things like love and human decency and
solidarity with those who are suffering
and he doesn't think that there's any
easy solutions to these so I think he's
really a great person for our own times
I gave you a timeline that has two sides
to it and I shouldn't mention too if you
guys have any questions at any point
just go ahead and interrupt me and I'll
you know
we'll discuss things and then I'll come
back to where I was intending to go on
I'm quite used to that so if there's
anything that jumps out at you so I put
it into two columns there's what happens
to Camus in his life and then there's
what's going on in primarily Europe
although some things in Asia and some
things in America so you notice that he
really you know he's growing up in the
the aftereffect of the first world war
which was a catastrophe across Europe it
was sort of the end of an era of
optimism and and you know this this
notion that human beings would work
everything out civilization is just
getting better and better because you
know these highly civilized countries
gutting each other down and and throwing
their young men for the most part
although they were also a lot of will
women civilians who suffered into the
trenches and just getting them mowed
down and chewed up and it ends with a
bad resolution
you know Germany things never get fully
resolved there the via our republic is
not set on a good footing all these new
republics that are created or
democracies created in Eastern Europe by
carving up the austro-hungarian Empire
the Ottoman Empire or the Russian Empire
most of them don't survive the the they
don't have democratic institutions and
they wind up veering very far to the
left or very far to the right Russia
itself you know that goes through all of
these upheavals under the the Bolsheviks
and so he's living through this time and
the France of his time actually he
doesn't start out in France
he starts out in North Africa because
he's born there and he's not you know I
mean he is a French citizen but he's not
you know a French French person you
could say all right yeah and and and his
mother stayed there too and a little bit
of trivia going way forward one one
reason why he was reluctant to make any
really absolute statements about the
Algerian war was he would say listen my
mom's here I don't want people killing
her and I think I was a perfectly he's
the whole thing to say but so he his
father you know dies in a battle during
World War one and he moves in with his
grandparents and he goes to school and
you know sort of like you know we look
at some of these other figures like
starts you know goes to the great
schools and all that because he's from
he's from Paris come who was a
provincial he is a he's an outsider
literally another translator of the the
stranger is the outsider right and and
he he has a rough time as a kid
he gets tuberculosis which affects your
lungs he plays soccer you know he gets
to go to school and graduates but the
places that he's going to they don't
have the sort of resources that the area
of Paris was the center of the French
world really in a way that's hard for us
to imagine here in America and it still
is everything that that this is the way
the Parisians think about it everything
that matters happens in Paris you know
if you're gonna study you study in Paris
why would you bother with any of this
other stuff and and it can it can
provoke a kind of sense of inferiority
you might say which he I don't think he
suffered from but he certainly was
attuned to how things were for those who
aren't in the elite you know he's
somebody who's growing up in the masses
and he ends up going to the University
of Elle's year when he's about 20 years
old gets married gets this lease house
to philosophy and and then joins the
French Communist Party as you could kind
of expect somebody who's committed to
benefiting the poor and and and
ameliorating their condition the French
Communist Party was one of the few that
was concerned with that sort of thing he
won't actually stay in the Communist
Party that well because he you know
here's a hard time he's the person sort
of at the back of the room raising their
hand saying I think you guys are doing
the right thing but what about this this
other thing that you're doing and then
everyone tells him to shut up you know
the way we're not been do things so the
Communists did that sort of thing and he
starts um working with theater he founds
this Piazza by the workers theater you
could say the laborers theater but the
idea was you'd put on plays and these
would be serving you know sort of two
purposes well three purposes really
entertainment would be one of them
there's a legitimate I think need on
people's part for some sort of
entertainment right and they would also
be introducing the workers to culture
allowing them to have the benefit of of
what the normally has just reserved for
the elites and it could work through the
sort of plays that they would put on to
help raise consciousness for them as
well and he does write his dissertation
which is on Christian thought and
Neoplatonism it does get published I
don't think it's translated at this
point and I don't think anybody is
interested in translating it I haven't
read it it might be quite good but it
might not be if it's like a lot of
dissertations you know dissertations are
your first work a lot of people have
these high expectations this is a total
digression a lot of people have these
high expectations for their
dissertations I encounter graduate
students are like I'm gonna write this
wonderful piece and I got this advice
when I was working on my own
dissertation that I totally ignored to
my own detriment from one of my
dissertation committee he said the only
good dissertation is a done dissertation
pick a simple topic write about it don't
try to change the world don't try to do
anything just get the hell out of here
and then write your good books later
yeah exactly and it makes perfect sense
right the first time that you do
something like you make a cake and
you're gonna put frosting on it it's
gonna look like crap so why would you
expect it to be any different with your
first book right and I never ended up
publishing my dissertation because I was
kind of a mess and I and I tell young
graduate students now the same sort of
thing just just pick something easy that
you can get done and then write your
good stuff later on and maybe it may
become who did that maybe he didn't and
certainly you wrote a lot of good stuff
later on but he doesn't go for
aggregation which would allow him to
teach because a recurrence of his
tuberculosis and you notice what's
happening during all this time this is
leading us up to about 36 so the Great
Depression has happened France we don't
often think of this but France was one
of the big powers at the time
and they were really pushing the Germans
around you know the at the same time
that that the Nazi Party is rising and
you've got all this far-right activity
and you know street battles between the
Nazis and the Communists and the Social
Democrats sort of stuck in between you
also have a France that is lining up
allies trying to ring Germany in and
trying to crush Germany economically as
much as they can France invades Germany
and takes over the Ruhr which is their
industrial center so there's a lot of
back and forth on both sides and and
French politics were just a mess as well
many times people again here's a bit of
a digression today people will often
want to like in America to the Roman
Empire and say we're at the end of our
our development and and I you know
there's a book by William Shire called
the fall of the French Third Republic
and when people start making all these
Rome analogies or other analogies like
that I say you want to understand where
America is today read that book because
what you had is a paralyzed political
system that couldn't actually get
anything done with incredible
ideological divides and rancor between
the left and the right and within the
left and the right about you know what
it meant to be on the left or on the
right and they were unable to see the
threats that were coming and deal with
them effectively because Hitler could
have been snuffed out so easily the
entire Nazi apparatus in as a matter of
fact when Hitler started engaging in his
his processes of you know slowly
swallowing up you know Austria and
Czechoslovakia he was terrified of the
idea that the French might actually grow
some some backbone this is the French
generals that he's worried about because
the French generals were the ones
there's no no no we shouldn't do
anything the French politicians actually
wanted to go and invade and they were
very worried that they might do that
they didn't and you know the emboldened
fascist regimes then marched all over
and eventually you know
Poland but you know the the the French
Republic that he's seeing is falling
apart it's dysfunctional and he's also
seeing it not only in terms of France
and the rest of Europe he's seeing it as
a person in Algeria looking northward to
the the mother country and and how
things are working out in the relations
between them so he starts publishing
things and and starts writing he joins
the staff of a newspaper and he writes
his first play Caligula which would be
put on much later on and eventually he
goes to France and this is in 1940 a
very propitious year for a lot of things
but also a very dismal year that's the
year that that Germany invades and
crushes France in the blitzkrieg that
goes across Holland and Belgium and
France destroys the French army you know
hundreds of thousands of young Frenchmen
are taken prisoner of war including
jean-paul sartre by the way who writes
some some notebooks while he's in the
prison camps and France is divided into
the the Vichy regime in the south run by
marshal patan who's on the right and and
willing to cooperate with the Nazi
regime and the rest of France is
occupied and the Nazis begin to impose
demands in in 1942 they can script well
the first things they call for
volunteers they only get 17,000
volunteers but they wanted 250,000 young
people to vote to volunteer and work for
the Nazis when they don't get volunteers
they just start rounding him up and then
the next year they asked for another
quarter of a million young men and women
to work while this is going on Camus is
in in Paris he's already becoming
divorced he gets remarried he goes to
Paris and gauges and some journalism
goes back to Algeria and then in 42 he
returns to France and he joins this
resistance organization combat combat
was the Journal of the resistance and
it's bringing together all these
different people who you know if it
wasn't for the fact that they hated the
the Nazi occupation they probably
wouldn't seem to die on a lot of things
and as a matter of fact later on they
they wouldn't and he ends up becoming
the director of the journal and then he
publishes two works that I think
probably are the ones he's best known
for
right the stranger often had they have
people in their French classes reading
that because it's such a simple story
and it's written that kind of a low
level in terms of difficulty and the
myth of synthesis which I often
mispronounced I'm sure somebody will
correct me on that what's that yeah
always does to me too but people tell me
that I get it wrong and and those are
about an absurd world and you know if
you if you've read the stranger you know
it's about this it's gamer soul who ends
up killing an Arab and then being
executed for it and doesn't have any
explanation for why he did it he's kind
of a detached guy and it's interesting
because a lot of people think that he is
you know what Camus is advocating and
Camus says this guy is a bastard he's
not at all what I'm what I'm you know
all about he's just one way that people
live in an absurd world it's not a model
for how you ought to be but a lot of
people have taken that that in that book
the mythos if it says so you got a novel
and you've got a philosophy book as
that's what Camus is all about but in
reality that's just the beginning he's
writing many other things and he's
constantly working as his thoughts are
further he meets jean-paul Sartre and
becomes friends with him at a dress
rehearsal of the moosh or the the Flies
which Sartre is putting on and combat
moves Camus publishes the
misunderstanding his children are are
born after the war is
to a close you get finding it's to put
his play on Caligula which I you know I
I'm not a playwright so I I don't really
have the cane of understanding what it
must be like to actually see a play that
you've written being performed I suppose
it'd be like if you were writing a book
and you see the book published or you
know you write a piece of music and
somebody plays it you know it must have
been a very big moment you notice that
there's there's years in between where
that's not happening the other thing
that happens in forty-five is he
publishes these four letters called
letters to a German friend and they're
very telling they begin by actually I'll
actually just pause and read you just a
little bit of though the first one he
says you said to me the greatness of my
country is beyond price anything is good
that contributes to its greatness and in
a world where everything has lost its
meaning those who like us young Germans
are lucky enough to find a meaning in
the destiny of our nation must sacrifice
everything else so there's you know this
is why a lot of people did embrace
Nazism they felt that the world was was
crap and and you know you've got to have
something that'll give your life some
direction to it and he says to his
friend I loved you then but at that
point we diverged no I told you I cannot
believe everything should be
subordinated to a single end there are
means that cannot be excused and I would
love this is a great line to be able to
love my country and still love justice I
don't want it just any greatness for it
particularly a greatness born of blood
and falsehood I want to keep it alive by
keeping justice alive and that his
friend says well you don't love your
country and so the letters are going
back and forth with this idea about can
you actually love the community that you
belong to but also subscribe to certain
universal values that you know you would
think as an existentialist or an
absurdist he couldn't
couldn't do but he does he thinks that
justice really is important he thought
that the Nazis lost sight of that and he
thought that the French were you know
vacillating and all that but when they
finally did get into the fight and they
had right on their side that made them
more or less unstoppable when we'll come
back to that in just a bit but I wanted
to say a little bit about that World War
two ends the United Nations gets founded
France gets a seat at the Security
Council you know they're back to being a
big power again and now a Europe is
divided between you know the Western
bloc and the Eastern Bloc with the
French kind of trying to sit out a lot
of the time and and you know Spain and
Portugal still under essentially
militaristic if not fascist regimes you
know the Franco and Salazar regime and
Qaboos you know he continues to publish
things he he writes a piece called
neither victims nor executioner's and
then he publishes the plague which I
think a lot of other people have read
it's one of his best novels it's a
really beautiful piece and then he
publishes this this state of siege as
well and the just assassins and by this
time now we're seeing the first
arab-israeli war and the the
intervention that is happening the
Berlin Blockade
starts NATO's created People's Republic
of China is created and the Chinese
Nationalist government goes to Taiwan
and we're seeing a world that's more and
more divided the world war didn't
actually settle anything even after
millions of casualties
you know fascism lost but now you've got
communism and you could call it a kind
of Americanism right a liberal democracy
but very much driven by by you know
American interests and capita
and then you know some others trying to
sort of sit it out and then there's
another thing that's happening at the
time as well which is D colonialization
France is involved by now in Indochina
because the Vietnamese you know wanted
them out and they they start losing
pretty badly and then you know the
British start losing bits of their
empire as well as do the Portuguese and
who else I mean the Spanish had bits and
pieces of things Camus continues working
and now he finds himself having
difficulties because he is on the left
he thinks that the the left in general
is the side that favor is the common
person that is looking out for the you
know the ordinary person the masses but
he's seeing what some of these regimes
that are supposed to be devoted to that
are doing particularly the Soviet Union
which you remember invades Hungary and
crushes the the revolution there he he
ends up splitting with Sartre and that
means not just splitting with Sartre
that means splitting with everybody
who's friends with Sartre like Simone de
Beauvoir and other you know a lot of
other followers and he's splitting
essentially over how you should view
communism then he publishes this the
rebel low-level Tay the man in or the
person in in revolt and this is really
his best book of philosophy it doesn't
get read very much doesn't get talked
about very much unfortunately but this
is his mature work it's not the end of
what his work would have been because he
dies rather young and someone tragically
but also you could say kind of comic
tragically right
driving a fast car you know he was you
know this is another thing to say
so Camus was a guy who liked to live
life hard you know he he enjoyed himself
a lot he you know he he got around in
terms of sexual liaisons and he
certainly you know lived life as much as
he could but he but he thought you also
had to you know respect certain ethical
limits and he was he was much more
preoccupied with you know violence than
anything else I would say but he you
know he was kind of yeah
fast fast and loose liver you could say
so it's not a surprise he died in a car
crash quite frankly he does start
protesting against Soviet repression and
he also gets involved in discussing the
Algerian war and the Algerian war was
pretty horrific after France retreats
from Vietnam D colonialization starts in
earnest because a lot of these other
countries start realizing that well if
you can kick him out of Vietnam why not
kick them out of here and the fnl
becomes the main you could say leader of
the revolution in Algeria there's other
groups involved as well and they're
getting backing from different different
places including Egypt under Nasser
which is part of why France actually
gets involved in the Suez war you know
when there's there's a second
arab-israeli war and the French I mean
I'm not going to say the French were the
only people doing things wrong in
Algeria both sides were you know very
early into the war committing horrible
atrocities and as a matter of fact
bombings were taking place in France and
not just a you know say Algerian
liberationists against French people it
was also of different factions of the
Algerian Liberation's against each other
in France
there was what was called the cafe war
where lots of people died as well so a
lot of bloodshed a lot of fighting a lot
of you know taking on other people as
threats and camus zone you know group
ends up turning on him because he what
he's advocating is is you know sort of a
cessation of violence he thinks there
should be a truce and people should try
to work things out and saying that makes
him unpopular with everybody unpopular
at the french unpopular with the
algerian liberationists unpopular with
the Pieta Noirs the the French Algerians
who are fleeing from the countryside who
you know farms had been you know by that
time taken but they've gotten their
farms because of confiscation of Muslims
farms at one time so there's all this
this terrible you know tragedy going on
around him and he doesn't have a easy
solution for things but he can't he can
spell out what the problem is in ways
that I think other people can he winds
up getting the Nobel Prize for
Literature which which is quite nice
because you know he's not going to live
much longer than that and like I
mentioned he doesn't actually see the
end of the Algerian war Charles de
Gaulle who you know of course it been
war hero for you know declaring you know
the free France and calling for for
enlistments to fight the Nazis
immediately oh I don't really like days
after patan starts his his regime he
becomes president of the the French
Fifth Republic because the Fourth
Republic Falls and it's de Gaulle who
actually is able to resolve Algeria and
he resolves it by it by leaving the last
thing I'll say about Algeria to just to
sort of put it in perspective you know
you think about the things that happened
in Vietnam under our occupation and war
they're you know many of them were tried
out first in Algeria by the French
may Paul mning people for example a
napalm is pretty horrific
you know dumping napalm over areas that
was a French tactic that was used
psyops you know the French actually
created a whole bunch of fake documents
and got the people in the FNL to turn on
each other thinking that you know
different ones were moles or traitors
things like that
both sides use torture pretty liberally
both sides to did you know atrocities
against civilians it was it was it was a
pretty terrible situation and come who
was you know reacting to that so that is
the history that he's he's engaged in
and so you could say I'm in one side so
the history is um conflict war
deprivation hostility and then on the
other side is well what leads people to
that is it just you know economic
motives or the drive for glory or is it
the fact that in the the 20th century a
lot of people thought that life had kind
of become meaningless and they're
looking for meaning in things that will
lead them into these conflicts that will
produce violence's as a way to deal with
what he calls the absurd so this is a
good sort of lead-in but I'm gonna stop
here for any questions that you have
before I talk about existentialism and
the absurd and get into the theory stuff
so if you have any questions or comments
well a lot of time at the end for that
too but no all right well let's let's
talk then first of all Camus I'm gonna
say is an existentialist he denied being
an existentialist so I've got to say why
he should be considered one well
existentialism is a very broad family
and when you think about the history of
philosophy and not everybody who is in
it called themselves an existentialist
and some of them actually repudiated the
term Camus isn't the only one Gabrielle
Marcel when he found out what Sartre
meant by it said I'm not an
existentialist anymore I'm a philosopher
of existence
Heidegger actually wrote a letter
the letter on humanism when Sartre was
using the turban said I'm not an
existentialist anymore either so that
you know whether they call themselves as
a statue list or not that's that's not
quite so important Camus when he talks
about your existentialist he means a
certain segment of them he means the
people who likes art and then he means
these religious existentialist like
certain Kierkegaard a lot of chefs Toth
who very few people read anymore Martin
Buber the Jewish philosopher and
Gabrielle Marcel so when he's targeting
the existentialist those are the people
that he means but nowadays we we place
them all into this big mat but I created
this handout for a different talk awhile
back and I thought it would be quite
useful for this so you got you know your
first phase of existentialism where
people aren't actually quite you know
realizing that it's a it's a thing you
know Kierkegaard uses the term
existential philosophy but he doesn't
call himself an existentialist and then
you got this guy Dostoevsky you know
he's arguably a philosopher he writes
novels but but he's you know those are
very philosophical and then you got
Friedrich Nietzsche definitely a
philosopher and you know you could
include your grandes in there the first
person to start you know recommending
Kierkegaard and Dostoevsky to Nietzsche
Imps n' I think could be in there
Tolstoy check off August Strindberg and
you notice it's sort of a primarily like
a northern European and Russian thing
right at that that time then we get the
second phase and some of these people
are actually using the word
existentialist here and drawing
connections between them like saying hey
character guard and Nietzsche those guys
were actually up to the same thing even
though one is an anti-christian and one
is like a Christian who thinks most
Christians aren't Christian enough
there's some common elements so you then
you get like chef stuff and yeah Spurs
and and in Spain or take a gossip
Gabrielle Marcel another guy in Spain
Unamuno you get some Russians
in there as well bear gif Rilke the poet
is is in there so is Kafka von den who
unfortunately dies in the camps he was
one of the only students of chest off
and then the third phase of
existentialism it like emerges out of
the shadows you could say and becomes
like a major going thing in philosophy
and you notice that that you know quite
a few of these people are French or they
write in French you call this the French
wave of existentialism with a few
exceptions right Ralph Ellison here in
the United States Franco you know
writing writing in German Welles Bultman
giddens Vanger but for the most part
these are these are French writers and
Camus fits into there and then we can
talk about how you know it became a big
thing here in the States and I would say
the the stuff in the States is mostly
influenced by the French and and Camus
would call what he was doing a
philosophy of the absurd and so a lot of
people want to say he's an absurdist but
that can be a little misleading because
when we think of like absurdist
playwrights they're the ones who have
just people doing random stuff and Camus
isn't about that the stranger could kind
of give you that impression
but the other novels that's not really
the case these are these are more like
Dostoevsky where the characters are you
know worrying about these moral dilemmas
and arguing with each other what should
I do
this seems you know like a lose-lose
situation either way you know how should
I handle this if you think about these
other works like the fall or the plague
that's really what's going on in there
right rather than oh I you know mother
died today or was it yesterday I don't
remember I'm actually mangling the start
of it but it's not this sort of you know
insouciance
that is not caring and it's people who
care too much in a lot of his works and
and so I think he really is an
existentialist and if yes
what does it mean to be an
existentialist one of the key ideas is
that the world it may have a meaning
some of the existentialist thought that
it wasn't totally absurd but we had to
do a lot of the work to to find that
meaning and most of our efforts to to
impose a meaning on the world were going
to be unsuccessful and Camus himself
talks about the world as being absurd
and he actually clarifies and saying
that the absurd is not just the world
being screwed up and lacking meaning
it's about us in the world he lays out
there's this beautiful sort of triatic
understanding of this in the mythos if
Issus where he says you have the human
being and the human being has you know
rationality and desires and wants the
the world which doesn't actually share
all those to fit that somehow we want
the world to be the way we want it to be
we want it to make sense we want things
in the world to be rational and and
Camus you know points out over and over
again you know you look at this you look
at this you look at this you look at
this these are all places where things
can like fall apart it could be as
simple as like looking in the mirror and
not recognizing yourself in the mirror
having that weird experience you know or
seeing other people they look kind of
mechanical or thinking about you know
what what modern natural science is
teaching us about the universe you know
used to be we thought it was this nice
law bound regular sphere and it turns
out not quite so much right there's
there's some weird things going
different places and then the scientists
try to fix it up with their theories and
then the phenomena resists them again
you know or think about you know
effective things like falling in love
well that's that's a huge mess right and
then being in a relationship another
huge mess things don't follow the way
that we want them to and he says that
the divorce uses that word divorce
between the world and the person that's
what the absurd is it's a third term
that's not reducible just to the world
and not just to the person I think it's
a great insight and then the question
was okay great what then and so on the
myth is synthesis
he says the the big philosophical
problem that's suicide
should we kill ourselves if the world
doesn't have any meaning and then maybe
we should just hang ourselves or you
know maybe and they discusses different
ways that a person can do this you know
he thinks that religion is a way of you
know killing your mind in a way I mean
he accuses some of the religious
existentialist of a failure of nerve
like that in his later works he's not
going to stop there so I gave you two
passages that I think are really good
for illustrating the difference between
these the first one is from the stranger
and he's it's kind of long but I'll read
it anyway says this is at the very end
where this priest is is trying to get
him to confess he says you're gonna feel
so much better if you do because then
you'll go to your death you know half
being right with God and the character
who's been kind of you know it kind of
lacks a basically just kind of going
along with stuff this this entire time
marisol he blows up at the priest and
he's you know here's what he said I
don't know how it was but something
seemed to break inside me and I started
yelling at the top of my voice I hurled
insults at him I told them not to waste
his rotten prayers on me it was better
to burn than to disappear I taken him by
the neck band of his cassock in a sort
of ecstasy of joy and rage I poured out
on him all the thoughts that had been
simmering in my brain he seemed so
cocksure you see and none of his
certainties were worth a strand of a
woman's hair living as he did at corpse
he couldn't even be sure of being alive
it might look as if my hands are empty
actually I was sure of myself sure about
everything far sure then he's sure of my
present life and of the death that was
coming that no doubt was all I had but
at least that certainty was something I
could get my teeth into just as it had
gotten its teeth into me I'd been right
I was still right I was always right
I'd passed my life in a certain way and
I might have passed it
different way if I'd felt like it I'd
acted thus and hadn't acted otherwise I
hadn't done acts whereas I done yrz
here's the key thing and what did that
mean that all the time I've been waiting
for this present moment for that dawn
tomorrow's or another's day which was to
justify me nothing nothing had the least
importance and I knew well why he too
knew well why was a beautiful phrase
from the dark horizon of my future a
sort of slow persistent breeze had been
blowing towards me all my life long from
the years that were to come and now on
that way that breeze had leveled out all
the ideas that people try to foist one
in the equally unreal years that I had
then was living through what difference
could they make to me the deaths of
others or have a mother's love or his
God or the way a man decides to live the
Fate he thinks he chooses since one in
the same fate was bound to choose not
only me but thousands of millions of
privileged people like him who called
them call themselves brothers surely
surely he must see that every man alive
was privileged there was only one class
of men the privileged class all alike
would become too condemned to die one
day his turn would come like the others
and what difference could it make if
after charged with murder he was
executed because he didn't weep at his
mother's funeral since it all came to
the same thing in the end so what's the
what's the what's the you know sort of
realization there nothing matters right
I mean you want to kill yourself kill
yourself if you don't want to kill
yourself great you know decide tomorrow
whether you're gonna do it because it
doesn't make any difference at all not
just your own death but the death of
others now look at the the next passage
from the rebel here he's engaging in
some retrospective and this is from the
very beginning of the work he says our
purpose is to find out whether innocence
the moment it becomes involved in action
can avoid committing murder this is a
really pressing question for not only
his time but our own time you know by
participating in a society are we
involving ourselves in injustice in
cruelty in
I'm actually I'll come back to this and
well I'll tell you one way in which this
comes up for for me quite often in like
teaching ethics classes and some of the
circles I move in which are food-related
if you think about factory farming it's
pretty horrific you know it's a recent
development - it's not like people
weren't abusing animals you know 40
years ago but they weren't abusing them
in a mechanical way that had so much
cruelty as we see now today and if you
want to buy you know meat or milk or
eggs that isn't factory farmed it costs
quite a bit more you know so one of the
things that one could do is become a
vegan but even that isn't completely
cruelty free because all that farming
you know if you start thinking about
animal suffering those mice who are
ground to a pulp under the the tines of
the the machines you know pulling up the
fields and suffer a moment of terror
before they're torn to shreds or
poisoned you know by pesticides - so
that we can grow the things there
there's no way you can eat without being
involved in some sort of suffering or
cruelty and so you could say well I can
minimize it very tough to do very tough
to even know that you're doing it
because you can buy stuff from this you
know ethic this thing that's got an
ethical stamp of approval and find out
that they lied and now are you
responsible for that you know and we
face these sorts of problems and Camus
was very conscious of this not only in
terms of say animal life but human life
so he says we can act only in terms of
our own time among the people who
surround us we shall know nothing until
we know whether we have the right to
kill our fellow men or the right to let
them be killed in that every action
today leads to murder director indirect
we cannot act until we know whether or
why we have the right to kill so the
important thing is not as yet to
the root of things but the world being
what it is to know how to live in it he
says in the age of negation he's always
talking about the past it was a sum
available they availed to examine one's
position concerning suicide in the age
of ideologies in the new age after World
War two we must examine our position in
relation to murder
if murder has rational foundations then
in our period and we ourselves are
rationally consequent if it has no
rational foundations we are insane and
there is no alternative but to find some
justification or to avert our faces it's
incumbent upon us to give a definite
answer to the question implicit in the
blood and strife of this century for we
are being put to the rack thirty years
ago before reaching a decision to kill
people denied many things to the point
of denying themselves by suicide God is
deceitful the whole world myself
included is deceitful therefore I choose
to die suicide was the problem then
etiology today is concerned only with
the denial of other human beings who
alone bear the responsibility of deceit
it's then we kill so he says this essay
proposes in the face of murder and
rebellion to pursue a train of thought
which began with suicide and the idea of
the absurd but for the moment this train
of thought yields only one concept that
of the absurd and the concept of the
absurd leads only to a contradiction as
far as the problem of murder is
concerned awareness of the absurd when
we lay claim to deduce a rule of
behavior from it makes murder seem a
matter of indifference to say the least
and hence possible and a little bit
later on in it he says in our daily
trials rebellion plays the same role as
the coach ito the Cartesian coach ito so
important for the French philosophers I
think therefore I am a sort of
self-assertion he says rebellion plays
the same role as a coach ito in the
realm of thought it is the first piece
of evidence but this evidence lures the
individual from its solitude it founds
its first value on the whole human race
IRA Bell
therefore we exist so it asserts a
beginning of solidarity it doesn't
automatically like make us all brothers
or
something like that but he talks and
that's that's part of what the rebel is
about analyzing different forms of
rebellion different ways in which people
deal with with an absurd world and how
they can okay
that's how they they can function within
its scope all right
so rebellion offers a possibility for
introducing something new a kind of
value into the world that the absurd is
always in the end gonna have the last
word on it's always gonna win but for a
while you can have something more it
could be love it could be you know the
class struggle it could be solidarity it
could be alleviating suffering it could
be all sorts of different things and he
thinks that that we we have to engage in
this so that's what he's doing in his
works he's engaging in acts of as he
would say revolting or rebelling or
standing up for something even knowing
that he's soonerlater gonna get get
knocked down again and he examines a
number of different ways in which
somebody might do that but really end up
giving in to an ideology so the you know
his talk with his Nazi friend is a great
example of that actually I'll read a
little bit more from one of the other
letters to a German friend he well
actually is from the first one he says
this is about the French we had we had
much to overcome first of all the
constant temptation to emulate you for
there's always something in us that
yields to instinct to contempt for
intelligence the cult of efficiency our
great virtues eventually become tiresome
to us we have become ashamed of our
intelligence and sometimes we imagine
some barbarous state of truth
barbarous state where truth would be
effortless but the cure for this is easy
you're there to show us what such
imagining would lead to if I believed in
some fatalism and history I would
suppose your place beside us
he lots of the intelligence as our
living
proof and he ends up talking about
overcoming another thing he says we had
to overcome our weakness for mankind the
image we'd formed of a peaceful destiny
that deep rooted conviction of ours that
no victory ever pays whereas any
mutilation of mankind is irrevocable we
had to give up our knowledge and our
hope the reasons we had for loving and
the loathing we had for war now we've
done all that we had to make a long
detour and we're far behind it's a
detour that regard for truth imposes on
intelligence that regard for friendship
imposes on the heart it's a detour that
safeguarded justice and put truth on the
side of those who question themselves he
says we paid dearly for this we paid
with humiliations and silences with
bitter experiences with prison sentences
with executions at dawn desertions and
separations daily pains of hunger
emaciated children and above all with
humiliation of our human dignity and and
so he's saying we we paid a pretty
horrific price for actually thinking
that values mattered and that we
wouldn't like just give in and be like
all the other bastards out there doing
whatever to try to succeed like like the
Nazis for example and I think there's
something to that there now it could
have been that the Nazis could have won
and the French could have been totally
wiped out
you know exploited into the the very
ground and and ultimately you know
destroyed it as a nation as the people
who they were conscripted into all sorts
of you know conditions that would have
brutalized them individually and
eventually destroyed them that didn't
happen
that was a possibility of history just
like so many you know places that did
happen right but by being willing to
stick with you know things that seem
antiquated like truth or justice and
allow them to impose demands on us even
though we've realized this is what Camus
would say even though we've realized
that it's really us choosing to allow
them to impose demands on us we keep
ourselves human in a way that the others
didn't
didn't the the Soviets didn't the people
who are given to revolutionary violence
in Algeria and saw no problem with with
killing civilians didn't and that's
that's really I think what his works are
about trying to understand and preserve
so I think he's a particularly timely
person for us to read in this this era
of hyper partisanship and thinking that
somehow one side could set everything
right you know because he the thing you
know I'll conclude it that's the one
thing that I do like about him is he's
not just saying well both sides are you
know bad so I'm just gonna step back and
not be involved with anybody
I'll just you know as well Terry said we
have to cultivate our garden so I've got
my little place here and everybody else
stays out of it no he was willing to you
know jump in and and take the you know
getting pounded down by his own side to
stand up and say this is right this is
wrong and so what we have here is
somebody who believes the world is
absurd doesn't have an inherent meaning
and yet thinks there are important
values that have to be stood up for and
is trying to diagnose how we do that you
know maybe not completely successfully
but and maybe not everything that he
says can be transposed directly onto our
own time but I think he offers us a very
interesting way to to look at the
history of our time so do you guys have
any questions or yeah yeah
yeah well well it's interesting because
there are still a very few neoplatonist
out there today's is there's total
aggression today November 7th is the day
that that in the Renaissance the
neoplatonist said that's Plato's
birthday sort of like people said you
know Jesus was born on December 25th
right nobody knows but they decided to
celebrate it and there are you know
there are still a few people out there
like doing Neoplatonic exercises who no
no no I mean they're definitely not a
yeah yeah as a matter of fact there's
there's there's a couple books recently
existentialism and romantic love by sky
Cleary there's an existentialist
Survival Guide that I haven't read and I
don't remember who that's why but it's
on my shelf to review so there are
people still interested in it and there
are people still quite interested in
some of the key figures like there's a
book out called surfing with Sartre you
know that came out in the last couple of
years you know drying on those two
things it's still a big interest in I'd
say Nietzsche and Kierkegaard and
Dostoevsky maybe lesson Camus as such
and I think the interest in him tends to
focus mostly on the early stuff not not
the later stuff because the early stuff
lets you you know be angsty and and so
this leads into a set another thing do
people get into the existentialist yes
adolescents do because they're all
alienated and they have to you know have
something that explains why the world
socks and so the existentialist are
there to provide that so if you teach a
class in in college on existentialism
it'll fill up now that's the that's the
existentialism as read by like 18
year-olds right and it's really
interesting I I bought into that right
and when I was
College I was you know reading Camus and
Sartre and Nietzsche and I read
Kierkegaard as like he's too religious
for me you know I don't really get this
this God stuff and I got certain themes
out of it that were helpful for me for
thinking about like okay what what
choices am I making and our are these
really my own responsibility and then
that I think that can be quite helpful
for a person to take responsibility now
you could get that through CBT you know
you get that through studying stoicism
there's other ways to realize that that
you have actually made part of the
situation you're in and made the person
who are but then when you start reading
these existentialist later on you start
reading them in your 30s and 40s you
start seeing lots of other things in
their works because they were older when
they're writing this that you missed the
first time around and you know for
example this book when I was in college
I read it and I thought yeah sign that
cow mooed you know his early stuff was
great that I can figure out this stuff I
don't know if the hell he's talking
about you know I read it as a person in
my 40s and I'm like wow this is pretty
deep there's amazing stuff here because
I think you know we do go through life
stages and and there may be ways to sort
of speed it up for some people and some
people actually just remain immature
their whole life to write but I think
most of us go through a normal kind of
progression where we get different
things out of these just as we might out
of like listening to music right you're
listening to music as a young person
unless you're really really talented
you're probably just hearing part of
what's going on you listen to the same
music when you're older and can pay more
attention to it you hear other things so
so I think the existentialist there is
interest in them they can be useful for
us I don't want to say that they're
providing us with something that we
can't get somewhere else but you know
they're putting things together in
interesting ways and and there isn't
like one single thing out there that
that's existentialism
Camus who's doing one thing there's
Sartre who's doing a related thing but
different in other ways there's de
Beauvoir who's you know doing other
things Marcel and we could go you know
sort of down the list you could say well
what do they all have in common you know
you can put them together in kind of a
comp as a picture but they're almost all
outliers from that that composite
picture Sartre was the guy who was super
successful in sort of taking over the
movement and defining what he meant by
it and pushing everybody else out but I
don't see any reason why we should
accept his his doing that you know yeah
what do you think I mean you you you've
read some of these figures do you think
they're useful for people today yeah I
mean you can remember the catch from
there everybody's a phony you're ice so
that's an existentialist novel in a way
but it's totally useless because first
of all not everybody is a phony sooner
or later you got to realize like there
is a difference between the people who
are just putting on airs and the people
who you actually like do need to go
all-in with but even if everybody else
was a phony what the hell good does that
do
pointing it all out yeah yeah and and
with with Camus you know I think that's
that's part of what's going on and you
know maybe to go back to the history
thing the fact that that the history
he's in just was so much just conflict
and you know people willing to gut each
other over you know the smallest
differences in ideas maybe that's
speeding up the process of thinking
these things through for him in a way
that doesn't happen for us because we're
a bit more insulated you know
so would you say his answer - yeah yeah
but you got to be you have to be careful
about what you pick right because one I
mean you could like say oh I'm gonna
stand up for something cool I'm gonna go
join whatever our equivalent of the
Nazis or the the Bolsheviks are yeah and
it has - you could say it has to
continue to contain justice over time
because it's really easy to like be just
at this point in time this is how people
join movements right these are the good
guys and then the good guys start
cutting corners and making deals and and
then suddenly they turned into what it
was that they were opposing right and at
that point in time you'd have to like
say well you guys are and if you do that
they'll kick you on the party right so
or shut you up in some way yeah exactly
yeah and I think he'd say you have to be
willing to go to face that so it's I
mean it means that the people who are
genuinely committed to doing the right
thing I'm probably not gonna be super
successful unfortunately you know I mean
you think about our own like party
system this is something I've been
thinking about for quite a while it is
possible to do good stuff in local
politics you know but once you start
catching the eyes of the movers and
shakers and they start having you meet
people and you start having to think
about how are you going to fund your
next campaign you you start to rise
through the ranks and you inevitably
become corrupted and I think in some
places more like I think Wisconsin is
probably better than Illinois I think
it's like impossible to rise above even
the most local level in Illinois without
becoming corrupt
our senators in Washington have a
building across the street where they
spend all their time because you're not
allowed to call for fundraising oh wow
yeah I mean if we've reached the point
where we've sort of boxed ourself into a
corner with how things are done and
anybody who wants like fix the system
from within they've got to go through
that like formation process and by the
time they reach the top they've been
corrupted by it I mean I think something
similar happens with corporations to
people or I'm gonna you know I'm gonna
join this and I when I get in I'm gonna
I'm gonna make things different and and
it's yeah and you can sometimes and
every once in a while you'll get like
one one person who's been waiting until
they're about to retire before they they
finally stick it to the system right but
but usually by that time somebody else
sees it coming and they're like they're
able to deflect it you know so yeah it's
too bad but it is it is the human
condition so then the question is well
what do we do is it's you know we could
say hot it's all crap then well you
still can get involved in local politics
and provided you don't succumb to the
desire to have everybody like you and
shape you so that you can you know
someday be a senator you could actually
get a lot done in local politics you
know it's sort of we've talked about
this the Peter Principle you guys
remember that that booked defeated
everyone rises to their level of
incompetence and one of the suggestions
that the guy who wrote it
Peter I forget what was something Peters
write was his name he talked about
creative incompetence which is rather
than allowing yourself to get promoted
from level to level you start like
screwing up in some way at the level
where you're happy
yeah so like maybe if you're a
politician you you have weird quirks
like you won't take corporate money at
this point and then they're not gonna
boost you up yeah yeah or I don't know
you could talk about something in a way
that alienates some voters or some
donors you know yeah any other questions
or comments or well yeah thanks for
being here and we're we're going to do
this again next year it's you know in
the spring we do somebody from ancient
philosophy and I've picked Epictetus the
stoic philosopher who started out as a
slave in the summer we do medieval
philosophies so we're gonna do st.
Thomas Aquinas and lose anything is long
overdue in the series we've done
Augustine boëthius and an some so far
and then in the modern in the fall we do
the modern period so we do those it this
time it's gonna be John Jacques Rousseau
we've done Locke and Hobbes and dick
earth and then in in the winter and I'm
calling this winter you know even though
we're not officially in winter yet yeah
that's when we do like the you know 20th
century philosophy people so I'm gonna
do some own to move water for that one
so I've got a good year ahead and yeah
this is the third year of this this
series
you